a gas stove has exploded on a train in
Pakistan sparking a huge fire that
killed at least 70 people survivors
recorded what happened as the flames
tore through several carriages the train
was on its way from Karachi to are well
pindy which is just outside Islamabad
there are more casualties due to the
speed of the Train wind accelerated the
fire that's why dozens of people are
dead and wounded let's get the latest on
c'mon Haider he's joining us from
Islamabad is there a fear Kemal that the
death toll could rise even further
absolutely because most of those people
who are still alive a badly burned these
are the victims of that fire on days
come which happened in district Rahim
Yar Khan about 150 kilometers from the
city of Multan now important to note
also that there were many missionaries
on board those four bogeys which caught
fire and apparently it was because of a
stove they were preparing breakfast
according to reports also the fact that
the train was moving at a considerable
speed which fueled the fire and the
train driver it took him a while to
realize that his bogies at the rear were
on fire now the military has been called
in helicopters to the rescue to move the
badly burned two hospitals burn units in
Multan and also doctors on the spot the
railways minister has also reached and
it is expected that the death toll is
likely to rise and railway accidents not
uncommon in Pakistan so will this once
again be raising questions about the
country's poor state of transport
infrastructure absolutely it should not
be forgotten that last year it was
estimated that 770 million people
travelled by train last year according
to the railways minister that figure is
now 80 million people travelling by
train annually
in Pakistan it is the cheapest mode of
transport but it has become obsolete
because not much attention has been
given to the state of the railways
it's an ageing system most of the
systems in fact are obsolete and this
pressure on the government to keep
running more and more trains so there
will be question marks as to how those
people were able to board that train
with cylinders and what could be
inflammable material there is no
security at the railway station so there
will be question marks as to whether
this crisis or this particular tragedy
could have been averted had there been
more vigilance at the railway stations
okay come on Haider thank you